[Music]
restrained with zip ties and marched out
of school by police at the age of six
kya roll was arrested on battery charges
when officers were called to her school
in Orlando last September after she had
a tantrum and allegedly assaulted staff
[Music]
her family have released the shocking
video which was filmed on a police body
camera to raise awareness Dennis Turner
was sacked as a reserve police officer
following the incident for violating
agency policy as he failed to get
approval from a supervisor before
arresting a child under 12 years old he
could be heard in the recording boasting
about arresting more than 6,000 people
and that kya was the youngest she's 8 to
6 now she had broken the record the
little girl's family say she suffers
from sleep apnea which can result in
behavioral issues shortly after her
arrest her grandmother told reporters
that the incident had been extremely
distressing no six-year-old child should
be able to tell somebody that they had
handcuffs on them and they were riding
in the back of a police car and taken to
a juvenile detention center to be
fingerprinted mug shot kaya had the
charges against her dropped as did a
six-year-old boy arrested by Turner on
the same day in a separate incident the
girl's family hoped that releasing the
footage will lead to a change in the law
barring children under 12 from ever
being arrested
Jenny Longdon Sky News